la déesse des mouches à feu et au
programme d'élèves de secondaire 5 à
l'école sophie barat sa part de la
tristesse sur un ton totalement neutre
avec des émotions qui sont pas attachés
anormalement basse à quoi on s'attache
avec la tristesse a tué plusieurs sujets
que je connais le com - la drogue qui la
mort de reproches billets puis elles à
la dépression puis d'autres domaines
j'ai l'impression qu'on a peur de
confronter justement à nos peurs et nos
craintes intérieur puis c'est de cette
façon que j'ai pu rejoindre les
personnes
une lecture qui a aussi séduit la
réalisatrice anaïs barbeau lavalette
c'est la première phase avait
l'impression de lire mon adolescence
pour quelqu'un au dessus mon épaule qui
me la raconte mais moi même qui est qui
qui à vif dans ce que ça peut être
l'adolescence avec tous ces vertiges à
elle signe une adaptation coup de poing
du roman à succès de jeunes vieilles
personnes qui s'est écoulé à près de
cinquante mille exemplaires
c'est un âge frontale donc je peux faire
attention parce que je mentirais à cet
âge là on y suit le passage tumultueux
de catherine de l'enfance à
l'adolescence une période marquante pour
le meilleur et pour le pire
je pense que c'est intense que tu es en
cherche de toi même qui était le but de
faire ce que tu veux
pete est quand même libre tant vite
crier elle découvre le sexe la drogue il
rock'n roll sur fond de couple parental
qui se déchire ses parents lui ont perdu
contrôle sur leur propre vie facal ou
6,1 à des chutes de perdre son contrôle
car les néron crève l'écran dans son
retour au jeu une première en douze ans
j'ai été très touché par tout scénario
je pleure à chaque page fait clair et je
me suis dit à qui je pense un bon moment
c'est le genre de rôle pour faire un
come back que j'ai envie de faire
la déesse des mouches à feu témoigne
avec justesse qu à vieillir quand on est
jeune on risque de se brûler les ailes
elle est comme cela je n'ai cessé trouve
que c'est juste un hommage à
l'adolescent ce thème lèvres la
réalisatrice anaïs barbeau-lavalette
avait un petit mot pour les ados qui ont
lu lives bowl ha à la déesse des mouches
à feu prendra l'affiché le 25 septembre
ici n'est bien alexandre chartier radio
canada montréal